hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be going over the closed Sicilian so
the Sicilian defense starts out with E
for c5 and then the main line is the
open Sicilian and that is Knight to f3
that's what most people are familiar
with and then Black's usually gonna play
Knight to c6 could play pawn d6 you can
have an exchange in the center of the
board
maybe Knight f6 Knight c3 you can get
into the knight Dorf defense it doesn't
matter what variation they accelerated
dragon the dragon all these variations
from black and the Sicilian defense have
very aggressive lines that's why a lot
of players when they're playing black
tend to prefer starting with the c5
because they have so many good lines and
you see some high wind percentages from
black which generally you tend to see
that on White's side of the board so the
closest iliyan says yeah we're not gonna
play Knight to f3 because that's where
most of the players are comfortable from
black side is if you play that Knight to
f3 so close Sicilian says I'm gonna play
Knight to c3 instead and I think there's
two main reasons why you would want to
play this the first one is most players
from black standpoint they don't have
something that's as aggressive that's
gonna win nearly as often against the
closed Sicilian the second reason is I
think it has some very easy repetitive
variations that you can go down so that
you don't have to wonder ok if they play
this variation because there's so much
theory behind the Sicilian defense where
you have to make sure you don't make any
mistakes when you play the closed
Sicilian you can pretty much stick to
the same game plan and have a really
really solid opening which from White's
standpoint I think that's many times
what you should be trying to do and not
trying to get caught up in did I
remember this one move in the specific
variation so we're gonna look at some of
the main lines that you'll see after you
play Knight to c3 here on the second
move the first variation that you may
see is Knight to c6 and from here I'd
recommend playing g3 yes there are other
options that you can play you can always
play Knight to e2 getting ready to push
forward with pawn and d4 you could just
play d3 right here
you could also bring your lights for a
bishop to be five so lots of different
options I think it's just easiest to go
ahead and play g3 this is gonna get
ready to fee and kinda the bishop here
to g2 you're gonna have an extremely
strong foundation eventually you will
play d3 both your bishops can get
outside the pawn chain and attack freely
but it's very difficult for black
doesn't matter what variation they play
to disrupt your plan which i think is a
very strong way to go if your opponent
is playing the Sicilian offense once you
play g3 they have some options if they
want to mirror the exact same thing
that's completely fine so g6 both of you
feeling kinda your bishops to the King
side of the board and that would just
play d3 getting ready to bring your dark
squared Bishop out here they may do the
same thing solidify their pawn chain d6
and then Knights at three getting ready
to castle on the King side they may do
the same thing Knight to f6 castle on
the King side they could play Bishop
down here to e6 they could castle on the
Kings side as well but you can see it's
pretty safe they're not putting much
pressure on white White has a very
strong foundation which is what you want
in the early game now if they don't go
with g6 early on maybe they don't want
to marry exactly what you are doing they
could instead just play Knight to f6 I
would still continue Bishop here to g2
and then maybe they want to push forward
with E 5 making sure that you don't push
forward here on a d4 that's completely
fine if they do that I would just play
d3 same thing as before if they want to
continue now with g7 you same plan
Knight to f3 getting ready to castle on
the King side as well if they say yeah I
don't want to think it over to the King
side maybe Bishop to e7 gay-rights a
castle as well you can still do the same
thing Knight to f3 now if we come back
instead of E 5 maybe they play d6 ok
from here we can just play d3 very
similar moves as before but really
doesn't matter where black goes they
can't stop us from doing what we're
trying
do now one thing that you will notice is
if they try the five now if they kind of
look at the calculations they may say
yes the the pawn can take right here or
even the knight can take and if the
knight takes there could be an exchange
right here but the Knights gonna move
and the knight and the Queen are both
defending this right now just the bishop
is defending this so yes there's only
one defender and two attackers from
black standpoint but then we're going to
be looking at Knight to e2 and then
after the Knight takes on d5 both sides
are equal in material but it's gonna be
hard for black to actually hold on to
all this material because of the move d4
now both sides have seven ponds but if
there is an exchange in the board after
Queen to d4 really White's gonna be
threatening c4 and this is going to
either win material or it's gonna put
black in a very very difficult spot even
if they decide to try to hold on to it
with e6 Castle kingside if you want to
to stop the the Queen coming down here
to put you in check but the eventual
move of c4 is really where blacks going
to be put in a tough spot so you won't
see d5 too often because they may not
even recognize how they can even try to
hold on to the material but if you do
see the e5 early on just know go ahead
and capture that material with your
Knights and then after there is an
exchange in the middle you are
eventually going to be looking to play
d4 and then c4 at some point
now instead of Knight to f6 from the
very beginning of this if you play this
g3 they could decide to play d6 now
these are all very common moves there
there's not a lot of variations that
they could go because you can see their
bishops can't move yet they it's kind of
blocked off their Knight really has
nowhere to go and the knight from here
is really only gonna come to f6 so
there's only few options that they will
you'll see here but if they do decide to
play d6 same things before Bishop to g2
if they play Knight to f6 get they're
not involved into the game still pawn to
d3
very very solid structure for white
nothing they can do to stop what you're
trying to do now they don't have to play
Knight to c3 another option that you
could see is pawn to e5 I would continue
with the same plan with g3 here hmmm a
could play Knight to c6 this would
essentially be the same thing as before
just a different move variation to get
here but Bishop to g3 here if instead
they play Knight to f6 I would still
play Bishop to g3 really the only thing
where I'm looking to do something
different is in this position if they
now decide okay after E 5 and we play
this g3 if they now decide to play g6 I
may change things up here and play
Knight to f3 and the main reason for
this is if they now decide to play
Bishop to g7 which is pretty common
trying to defend this pawn or even if
they decide Knight to c6 which is also
pretty common then we could play Bishop
to c4
so this Bishop is attacking this pawn
here on f7 and let's say they were to
bring Bishop to g7 and they don't have
to if they don't you can see we still
have a solid structure here we can
always play pawn to d3 castle on the
King side but they may continue with
their playing most of the time if you're
playing pawn to g6 you're gonna fee in
Quetta to the kings of the board but
once they do that then all of a sudden
Knight to b5 now this is threatening the
knight coming here to d6 check and then
black is gonna be forced to move their
King which is not what you want to be
doing in this setup so they may play d6
and then you have the pretty aggressive
move here of Knight to g5 so both the
bishop and the knight here are both
attacking this weakened square here on
f7 this would be the main reason that
early on I would play that Knight to f3
instead of thinking of my bishop here to
g2 because you will see this position
quite often and I think it's really good
from white standpoint so if we play that
and then maybe they take
the night here on a g5 which is kind of
the bait that we are putting out there
the night takes on d6 check your
opponent is going to be forced to move
now depending on where they move they
have lots of different options to mess
this up they could always play something
poorly like King to d8 and then you have
check and this is forking the Queen
right here if they move somewhere else
here you can still take this material
and it puts them in a world of hurt even
here you could play Knights takes on f7
and then your attacking both the Queen
and the rook right here so I really like
this position the King can no longer
castle would be the one place where I
would say I like the knight to f3
instead of bringing your Bishop here to
g2 next variation that you could see is
d6 this is the most common in the open
Sicilian and so you may also see it in
the close Sicilian as well
I would keep things pretty easy g3 here
if they want to continue with Knight to
c6 this is very similar setup as all the
other openings just a different move
order here
Bishop to G - maybe Knight f3 X Knight
f6 d3 it's all pretty much the same
right here
the main difference that you will see in
these openings is if they don't play a
standard move maybe instead of moving
one of these pawns or Knight to c6 they
instead start with Knight to f6 this
would absolutely be a mistake and you
won't see it all too often but I like to
make sure everyone knows what to do in
case your opponent does make a mistake
but hopefully you could see that a 5 is
going to be the right play here there's
real no good options here if the knight
moves anywhere except for g8 it is going
to fall you can see both of these light
squares right here covered by the Queen
from d1 here and both of these squares
right here covered by the knight so they
come back here to g8 that's not exactly
where you want to be and then I would be
extremely aggressive so I'd start out
with d4 trying to control the center as
much as possible here if they exchange
that's fine this is one of those spots
where I think getting the Queen involved
is accepted
because you have the advantage your
opponent if you look at their setup they
haven't moved anything they move their
night and then they moved it back so
nothing is moved one pawns come off the
board that's completely fine so even if
they play Knight to c6 to move the Queen
you still want to get the Queen involved
into the game you don't just want to
come back here to d1 you have to sense
weakness from your opponent continue to
attack so maybe e6 to get there dark
square Bishop ball to the game Knight to
f3 get your lights for Bishop involved
castle on the Kings side both of your
bishops can get very very active in the
board so make sure you do that but that
is an intro to the close Sicilian again
pretty straightforward if you're looking
for an opening if you you play a lot of
efore early on maybe you're trying to
try stuff out with the the King's gambit
or other variations and you just don't
want to see c5 because after you play
Knight f3 they have all these variations
that are very difficult to deal with
sometimes I would recommend playing the
close Sicilian Knight to c3 keep it
simple they really can't disrupt what
you're trying to do thank you guys so
much for watching another chess opening
video and I will see you guys in the
next one have a go